foreign
hey you guys it's Monday what's going on
hopefully everybody can hear us yeah it
looks like they can okay that's good I
always gotta check because sometimes the
microphone turns itself off randomly you
know yeah so it's another haunting
Mondays yes it is we're doing Dark
Forest
which was uh it's one of the older ones
but it's a good one season two this one
was yeah it's really weird because we
were going through like the first the
box set of the first four seasons and I
was like most of them I either we'd
either already covered them or I was
like I couldn't remember enough if we'd
like covered them or not but for some
reason this is the only one that we
didn't really
get into and I didn't actually remember
anything about it until we started
watching it and I don't know why because
it's actually like a pretty decent
episode yeah yeah I recognized a lot of
the witnesses
but I didn't remember the story no I
didn't either and uh but then like when
they brought out the psychic that
character and everything the way he's
many people have died in this house
and I was going oh yeah I remember this
one but I never really paid close
attention to the story really never
really tried to analyze it until until
watch it at this time trying to get a
grip on
what this phenomena might be and uh you
know we'll get into it yeah this was
that and actually there's quite a lot of
um
outside
stuff about this one because apparently
this house is uh quite famous okay I
didn't know that in that in that area
okay and uh yeah it's even on
TripAdvisor and everything like it has
the address you can go see it and like
the guy that owns it like gives tours of
it and [ __ ] like that same family
doesn't own it anymore obviously but
it's uh yeah and the woman that was on
here Clara Dandy
um that's not her last name anymore
because I guess she divorced her husband
but um she wrote a book about it
and that psychic has also written a
bunch of bit a bunch of books too he
actually wrote a book called
is your child psychic or something or
how to tell if your child's psychic
something he has like four or five of
them on Amazon I'm not sure I thought
maybe he was still alive although he
said if he's still alive he's 96 years
old okay but I'm not really sure if he's
still alive or not 96 he's doing good if
he's still alive well yeah I don't know
if he is or not because like if he
doesn't have a Wikipedia page but like
when I when I Googled him it's like it
came up and it said that what Yuri was
born and said 96 years old but it didn't
say if he was like alive or dead dude
yeah it could be so it's possible that
it's possible that he's still alive yeah
this uh story had a lot of interesting
um
points to it a little data points uh
Concepts that don't really come up in
typical haunting cases like how the
church handled it and everything which
made it a little bit more interesting
you know usually the church the church
gets involved they don't want anything
to do with it yeah it's fake you're
crazy or it's demons or they come in and
they're just like and then they get
scared and they're like all right bless
bye good luck with that yeah they don't
want anything to do they're like this
ghost here ma'am I know about those
little boys I gotta get out of here yeah
before I get into trouble he's going to
start talking with him just start
talking about them little boys I gotta
split
so uh maybe that's what it is yeah
that's why they always run out of there
but this one this one
soon as the priest heard about it he
goes I think this is Poltergeist
I was like oh man [ __ ] prison he goes
we need to get a psychic investigator in
on this so he's really he did bless and
did did some churchly [ __ ] I got your
back go ahead and investigate you know I
got the church angle back there Jesus is
watching over you you know he's in
church yeah which uh I was kind of
impressed with that kind of It kind of
lends a little error credibility to it
that um or at least in this case that
the the church kind of did the the best
thing [ __ ] let somebody who you know
he the the priest went to a
parapsychology
angle it says this is [ __ ] culture
guys to coming out of one of these kids
you know psychokinetic abilities
it says we just need to talk to a
[ __ ]
psychic
now the psychics interpretation of what
it was
he's going to come and say it's a
haunting but you know
he did get rid of it kind of or
supposedly no he didn't no he didn't
like it got rid of it for well spoiler
alert uh they got rid of it for a while
like for a few months but then it came
back apparently so yeah so he wasn't a
whole lot of help I guess
and we'll get in we'll get into it too
because like some of the stuff he said
um as far as I know like turned out
later they that when they went to
research that that was that was not
really fun yeah yeah so I figured yeah I
tend to do that man well yeah they're
like they just want a good story because
it's like nobody nobody wants you know
if you're having like weird [ __ ] happen
in your house and you call like a
Paranormal Investigator nobody wants
them to come in and just be like well
nothing exciting ever happened in this
house they always want everybody wants
something like salacious yeah everything
like that you know yeah makes it much
easier to like get a handle on I suppose
church should got a pair of psychologist
instead of a psychic
yeah I know I mean I kind of thought
that that's where now apparently this
guy though I guess I found like a paper
that was written about him like about
his like I don't I couldn't read it
because it was like behind a paywall but
uh It Was Written in 2013 and it was
about like testing his abilities and
stuff yeah so and it was like a
university that had done it like I was
like some kind of para or some for some
kind of like parapsychological
anthropological journal or something
yeah I'm not down and on psychics uh
there have been psychics that have ended
Poltergeist phenomena you know what I
mean
um but this particular one didn't
um
right yeah and then apparently it came
back I mean at least according to Family
I'm not really sure who's in here
everybody here who's in here who's in
here
but yeah so uh I was yeah I was
pleasantly surprised this is actually
like a better episode than I wrote like
once I started watching it I kind of
remembered I remembered the people I
just never remember exactly what
happened in it because a lot of them
were kind of
you know I don't know if that's the
other Sami but a lot of them were
similar and I get them like mixed up
because usually what what we used to do
is we used to watch them you know like a
bunch of them in a row so sometimes I'd
mix up the details unless it was like
super distinctive
and so I think Tom Sykes said earlier I
don't think it's there anymore but um he
said this one's kind of like is this one
kind of like the one last week was like
the two boys
finding the um
like the spirit and the forest I said
this does have a slight tinge of that
it's not it wasn't actually brothers it
was like the one of the kids was a boy
and he had a couple friends and they
went out in the woods and they suspected
that something was out in the woods that
came in the house but I don't know if
that's true or not yeah they were going
out they were going out of the woods
scaring themselves
pretty much but there's no they heard
some stuff but you can hear a lot of
stuff in the woods okay that's true
um they blamed it on being out they they
Associated being out in the woods being
scared with this Poltergeist thing
in my experience it could have been that
getting freaked out and getting scared
out in the woods may have attributed
given the energy you needed later on to
put
I guess a bunch of fear in the
atmosphere of the house which could
bring about bring about our rspk
turn spontaneous cytokinesis yeah
but
rsvk and the Poltergeist didn't come
from outside just that being scared
helped you generate it yeah so it's a
little bit different than the last one
because the last one they said they saw
yeah like Shadow People type things like
out in the woods
they believed they saw they believed
they saw yeah that's enough to freak you
out sure yeah I'd be freaked out if I
thought I saw a little yeah maybe they
didn't maybe they didn't really see it
they just thought they saw it
and then that helped bring about a
poltergeist
you know I mean it's always in the
telling of the story yeah you know maybe
some of these people are way more
imaginative than right because like I
don't I don't usually see anything that
weird I was getting scared [ __ ]
driving up to Mammoth Mountain I was
getting a feeling of Doom and and it's
that and that's all it took us started
yeah that's true you know because you
were probably thinking about The Shining
yeah I was thinking about The Shining
stuff
that's what's going to happen yeah it's
gonna be harder when I get up there
watch yeah I mean it [ __ ] work you
were right see yeah you did it but I
generated it you did it yeah okay
yeah so did I mention that this is yeah
season two episode seven season two
episode seven yeah so do you think we
should get into it or okay so I'm just
wondering if you had like something else
to say no we're ready to go so we're
gonna talk about people in there [ __ ]
we'll go all right we're gonna have all
we don't have all night anyway
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah it's like we've got to eat some
dinner and then we gotta oh and we gotta
watch uh night of the Comet because
that's the movie we're gonna be talking
about tomorrow that was uh because
remember if you're uh on our patreon
patreon which if you're not you should
be uh you can go in there and vote I
made it now so you could vote on the
matinee movies like the Sunday movie and
the Tuesday movie so that's the one that
won the vote we're looking for more
patrons we used to get like 600 bucks a
month at patreon money this is a couple
years back and over the past couple
years it's like doing it all down to
like 300 it's sucking
it's enough to make a difference you
know and I hate for Jenny to have to get
a job I would hate that too stop doing
the show and all that [ __ ] [ __ ] so
um Patron patrons were really uh helping
us out so if you guys we're looking for
patrons if you want to be a patron even
if it's only like five bucks a month
that would really help us out we're
we're at that point now and like I said
even if you can't do that it's good to
uh like the videos comment on the videos
all that kind of stuff because that's
all scrapped your friends that all like
pushes stuff up in the algorithms too
because if we get more subscribers then
that'll be good also yeah we're almost
at 13 000. so I'm kind of excited about
that
so this story right here uh this took
place right here okay in 1970 that's
when it started this is the Dandy family
they're a Dandy family I'm sure they got
that all the time back then they're like
yeah we've heard it shut the [ __ ] up so
this happened in Hinsdale New York which
I guess it's like Western New York like
kind of a rural mountainous area I think
the way that they were saying it was
like 70-ish miles from Buffalo
so the house that's there and like I
said I mean
I I debated because I do have the
address like farther down because I
found it like very very easily like I
said it's on TripAdvisor so I guess in
this case I'll give the address out
later on because they don't really seem
to mind because it's on TripAdvisor and
like I said they give tours and [ __ ] and
there was people you know that had that
had been on tours and like took pictures
out in front of it so I guess like
nobody cares so I'll say uh what the
address was so apparently the house is
still there
so uh so yeah it's on eight Acres
so the family had actually lived in
Buffalo New York but they had been
vacationing in this kind of rural area
for many years before deciding they were
going to get out of the rat race of
Buffalo New York and uh move into the
country so the dad whose name is Phil uh
he's still gonna keep his job in Buffalo
and commute 70 miles I don't know if
that's 70 miles one way or 70 miles both
ways either way [ __ ] that yeah that's
right I don't think so I don't want to
live out in the country that bad
uh so they moved out there in 1970 as I
mentioned so Clara who is uh the
matriarch now she's uh she was on there
for real it was her and the son whose
name was Mike and then like some other
people later like I'm guessing that her
and Phil got divorced because her last
name was different later so he wasn't on
there talking
so she said that the house when they
went out there like I said it was just
kind of on this big flat piece of sort
of like farmlandish type situation she
said it looked really peaceful when they
first saw it and she said a very weird
thing she said the air was like
breathing champagne
and I was like so like drowning in
bubbles I mean I guess I get what she's
going for but I was like I thought that
was just like a weird way to freezing uh
so yeah so this is like an old house
it's like over 100 years old and it's
actually pretty big it's not quite as
big as the one they show in the show
because I've seen pictures of the real
one
um but it's similar it looked kind of
similar
so they also got two kids uh they got a
13 year old daughter named Tina and a 14
year old sunday Mike I think that's what
it was there were 13 and 14. uh so like
I said Mike appears on the show like as
a grown-up obviously
so Mike said he was real into Wildlife
like at the time so he really liked all
the woods that surrounded the house so
he would like go and hang out back there
so when they're in there deciding to buy
the house uh you know with the realtor
and all that they see that there's a
door that goes to like a crawl space
type closet kind of thing like under the
stairs
so the door is stuck but they eventually
kind of pry it open
so Clara said even before they moved in
she said she thought the crawl space was
weird like looking in it like gave her a
funny feeling because like inside there
like I said it was kind of like an
understeers
closet type thing
um and she said there was like an old
bricked up fireplace in there which she
thought was really strange and then she
was just kind of like well maybe it's
just because I grew up in the city and
I've never been out in the country
really all that much and maybe that's
just what they do out here I don't
really know so it's just kind of like
okay whatever to me it sounds like the
uh the house was redesigned that's kind
of what I was suspecting too that maybe
that was like part of another room and
then they just like made into a storage
thing you know like what happens all
over hundreds of years and move the
stairs there weren't stairs there the
stairs were somewhere else and they
built a new staircase of where the
fireplace was that's what it sounds like
yeah that's probably what happened and
they turned it into a like a closet
I gotta vary when they opened that that
crawl space door and like there was the
red brick in the back I got a very
Amityville Horror Vibe yeah
so this apparently happened before all
of that ambival horror nonsense but you
know that's why they bricked the uh the
fireplace up you couldn't use a
fireplace that was underneath the dam in
the closet yeah that would be done don't
do that yeah
so uh Tom Sykes says slave quarters
Maybe
no well I don't know
I I yeah I kind of suspect that they
probably just the house was probably
just redesigned or remodeled or
something was it Like torian Houses
didn't make any goddamn sense I lived in
one
yeah you had to walk through all the
rooms to get anywhere
there was no Central hallway that always
like cracked me up yeah let's go to the
bathroom me walking through people's
rooms hey what's up yeah yeah
like what kind of room is this it's just
a room room everybody's like sleeping or
like sitting in front of the computer
jerking off or whatever it is they're
doing and then like you're like walking
through the rims excuse me the house
with no hallways
that's just so weird to me yeah and it
wasn't always like that they had changed
it a couple times I mean some floors did
have holloways the bottom floor didn't
people's people's lives were much
different well I kind of feel like too I
think I mean at least just from from
what I've read is that in the old days
if you had a two-story house like the
first floor was considered like the
public floor that was where you met
guests and everything like that so they
didn't really have yeah no no then it
was everything else was bedrooms right
and so the downstairs but the thing is
in the modern era they're trying to rent
each floor out yeah you know what I mean
from to multiple people you know yeah
they try to turn them into like
Apartments yeah basically they didn't
make any goddamn sense
don't make any goddam said yeah
and uh I don't think uh home builders
[ __ ] thought too much about anything
they just laid out they laid out the
ribs to look pretty they didn't think
about
utility that much not the Victorian era
yeah they were just like they're just
like yeah we're just gonna put a bunch
of rooms together when I was in the city
room and she'll just like it yeah none
of the [ __ ] was [ __ ] efficient never
made any sense and we'll put a parlor
here and another parlor over here and
some rooms here so many people put the
bathtub right there you know so
everybody can troop through and watch it
it's like your old back scrubber you
know what I mean hey what's up uh so
yeah so she I don't know she just
thought that was like weird that was
there so anyway
so a few months after they buy the house
they move in so Clara's brother I don't
know if they said what his name was but
he was helping them with the move and he
actually got to the house a few hours
before they did like with his truck and
he was taking uh stuff inside like boxes
and [ __ ]
now as soon as he opened the front door
like a couple of bees like flew out at
him
and then when he went inside the house
he noticed there was just loads and
loads of like dead bees all over the
floor and then plus there was like a
[ __ ] ton of live ones like crawling all
over the window so again very Amityville
Horror that except you know that was
flies obviously but same same principle
anyway
so the rest of the family gets there and
the brother is like walking out with a
dustpan full of dead bees and Claire is
like what the [ __ ] and he's like man the
place is just full of bees you know what
I mean
um and they thought it was a little bit
weird because they said well it's not
really the time of year that bees would
be swarming around or anything like that
but you know Clara just kind of brushed
it off she's like well I guess I'll have
to get used to living out here in the
country with all these [ __ ] creatures
and all that so she said other than that
I mean there wasn't anything weird at
the beginning like they really liked
living out there they said it was a lot
more relaxing than living in the city
and it was just kind of Ideal for them
and they were just having a great
[ __ ] time
few weeks after they moved in though
Mike who's the son and a couple of the
neighbor kids are out exploring the
woods
uh so the neighbor boys are like yeah
man we know these Woods like the back of
our hand but then you know they didn't
really seem to it's like yeah which way
of my house then um I don't know that
way so you know they're full of [ __ ] so
while they're in the woods they hear
kind of Twigs breaking like maybe a
footstep or something
and then they see this tall what looked
like a teenage boy like walking past
them carrying like a rifle right so they
yell after the kid telling him it's like
hey this is private property like what
are you doing here but he just ignores
them so they run after him for a little
bit but then he seems to just kind of
like disappear into the surrounding
woods and they're not entirely sure
where he could have gone I'm not super
clear on whether they actually saw him
like wink out of existence or the way
that the reenactment showed it was that
they were following him and they could
see him and they could see him and then
like they kind of crested a ridge or
something they looked down and then he
was just gone and there's like nowhere
that he could have gone and that
grown-up Mike actually said said he
disappeared but I don't know what he
meant you know what I mean I don't know
if he meant he actually went and
disappeared or what or they just didn't
know where he went to
so Mike runs back to his house and tells
his mom that they saw a ghost and the
fact that he told her that makes me
suspect that maybe they did see him
disappear because otherwise they would
just think it was a guy right
uh so while they're telling her that
though like the mom's on the phone and
she's not really listening like yeah
whatever you know what I mean like she
couldn't really be bothered because she
was kind of busy
now a few weeks after that
um Clara has kind of like forgotten
about Mike's whole story about seeing
the ghost in the woods but she's out in
the woods walking the dog whose name is
Madison by the way
and she hears something while she's out
in the woods that she said sounded like
Gregorian chants which would be a little
weird hearing that coming out of nowhere
and she also said that she felt uh
surrounded by something that's a quote
so the dog seemed also wigged out by
this situation and kind of like takes
off running so she kind of like chases
the dog home
so Claire was telling her husband
because he's away at work all the time
like I said he works in Buffalo still so
he's you know not home as much because
of the commute and everything so she
calls him and tells about this weird
noise she heard in the woods but he
doesn't
entirely believe her she said I'm not
sure he actually like disbelieved me but
he was just kind of like yeah whatever I
don't have time for this [ __ ] right
now or something like that so like I
said he's away at work a lot so she kind
of feels like a little bit
unsupported I suppose
so she tells Mike about this sound just
like yeah I heard this weird chanting
like out in the woods
so Mike is trying to come up with
something he's like well you know there
was a campground not too far from where
they lived it's like maybe somebody was
at the campground and they were like
playing a radio which they just happened
to be playing Gregorian chants or
something like that it's like who knows
so it's like maybe it was that maybe
there's a logical explanation but they
kind of suspect that maybe there might
be something weird going on so him and
the two other kids the two boys go into
the woods to the same place where the
mom was to see if they could hear the
same noise as well just to like check it
out
so while they're going out there I guess
like nothing really egregious happened
but they started getting creeped out it
was a daytime it was at night and so one
of the kids started to go back
but Mike and one of the other kids whose
name was Matt uh they continue on into
this kind of like clearing type of thing
and then they said it feels kind of
weird right here so they decide they're
just gonna stand there and like close
their eyes and sort of like meditate and
see if any Supernatural [ __ ] happens
right
yeah they work that seemed like they
were kind of what they were trying to do
like they were trying to like commune
with whatever was uh was out there in
the woods or whatever so they do that
for a few minutes and then Mike's like
uh nothing's happening this is [ __ ]
and Matt's like just chill just you know
just concentrate yeah it might be enough
to start Poltergeist it might be you
know just just trying to bring it to the
Forefront hey let's see some weird [ __ ]
happen that might be enough to start the
process of tension and stress that you
need expectation yeah yeah it is
interesting how this one started out the
same kind of way like yes
just the suggestion of something in the
woods you know what I mean Camp guy said
you all got me to watch a couple
episodes of Hoarders oh man we watched
another one last night too and let they
got another bag [ __ ] dude [ __ ] in
bags they got another bag just keeping
it kidney throws his own [ __ ] away
every now and then you do come across a
bag [ __ ] on that [ __ ] because as soon
as I like it came on I'm like oh no it's
another bag shedder
that's the worst con man yeah once once
they start shooting in bags that's uh
that's pretty much all that's a wrap
they usually can't be helped yeah you
know what I mean they sometimes I think
the one woman they had on there a long
time ago that was a bad [ __ ] I think
they had to like uh have her committed
yeah they kicked her out of her house
and I and I think I think they tore the
house down because it was like
completely destroyed yeah the [ __ ] had
eaten through the floor yeah the ceiling
yeah because she was she's just stacking
it up in the bathroom in the bathroom
corner on the bathroom Corner [ __ ] a
whole [ __ ] bathroom with stacked the
[ __ ] bags of [ __ ]
and it had eaten through the floor yeah
nasty [ __ ] man
yeah same thing happened with this guy
and she laughed it off like it was no
big deal yeah it's really weird like I
said that's her ass walked off and
[ __ ] got into a damn van
took her away [ __ ] she laughed the
whole way that's what I mean to the
[ __ ] loony band
yeah back shutters man yeah every time I
see that I'm just like oh no it's not
bad yeah that's like so gross it just
makes me want to like [ __ ] vomit
watching that stuff all right so where
was I okay so the two boys are like out
in the woods doing their you know
closing their eyes and trying to
concentrate or whatever
and while they're doing that they said
they heard a sound they said it sounded
like an ax hitting wood like somebody
hitting a tree or a log or something
like with a with an ax it sounded like
that like thwack
and then they hear like the very
distinct sound of a woman screaming
which you know that freaks them out like
I said it could have been I kind of feel
like if I was in the woods and heard of
women screaming you might want to like
go and check that out because that could
actually be a human woman that's like in
trouble or something and she could be
getting murdered and like maybe you want
to help her out a lot of animals that
sound like that well yeah that too
doesn't sound like I wouldn't just I
wouldn't immediately jump to ghost is
what I'm saying peacocks can [ __ ]
sound like that they say a peacock
sounds just like a screaming woman it
does I've never heard it I've heard it
yeah
not exactly like a screaming woman but
similar enough that if you heard it it
would like really it's a weird sound
peacocks make a really weird sound a
rabbit getting eaten up [ __ ] getting
shaken to death or [ __ ] under a lot
of stress can make a cry that sounds
like a like a little child or a
person from a distance it might be able
to fool you
so you know I
I don't know what to make of it what
they're saying it could be it could be a
lot yeah I mean if it was I mean
Gregorian chants is much weirder sorry
I'm having this so I can write some
stuff down because Tom Sykes had a
paranormal show about the famous medium
uh the Eddie Brothers Horatio and
William Eddie
from Vermont would make a good show
actually that's cool because I don't
think I've ever heard of that before so
I'm going to write that down but yeah so
if it was anything other than a scream
um I don't know I just kind of feel like
Gregorian chants is weird a woman
screaming you might want to check that
out because like I said it could be an
actual woman screaming who's getting
murdered by a serial killer or it could
be an animal like you said it could be a
peacock or lots of other thing or a fox
or lots of other things there's a lot of
things that can happen
in a natural environment if your mind's
playing tricks on you and you're trying
to listen real hard you'll kind of
sometimes hear whatever it is you want
to hear
I remember that too I remember we'd be
up in Korea
and [ __ ] it was just the sound of
wind blowing through the trees every now
and then and just regular sounds in
nature
I wanted to get the [ __ ] out of there
you know what I mean we were waiting for
something waiting for trucks
come get us
and um
I could swear I heard those trucks
coming and I heard those trucks coming
for five or six hours they never showed
up but if you listened long enough and
you listened hard enough because you
could
really think you really thought you
heard the trucks coming yeah I've had
that case but it's just the background
noise you know what I mean yeah and
you're amplifying it because you're
expecting you're expecting it something
else so I've had that happen they may
have been here and listening for
something and they
in their minds there's you hear that it
goes yeah it sounds like music yeah it
sounds kind of like Richard Gordon
chanting but they can't quite make it
out well now the mom heard that like by
herself the kids didn't hear that but
you know it might have just been her
yeah yeah just like putting your ear up
to a damn seashell you hear the you said
well being out in the dam
wild sometimes you hear that you just
hear just a like it's like a white noise
that you can pull anything out of it
you know you go oh that sounds like a
train the other guy goes no it sounds
like an airplane yeah no it sounds like
the ocean another guy's going no it
sounds you know it could be it sounds
like trucks you know it's just it's just
white noise and you're kind of just
pulling anything you want out of it
you know
Camp guy said uh about hoarders do they
have houses that they are not able to
clean out
they have ones well they have definitely
have ones that they don't finish because
they give themselves like a four day uh
limit and they I mean they do have a
massive crew so usually they get most of
it cleaned out but they have had uh
numerous occasions where they got it
partially cleaned out and then the house
was just kind of like
um not livable yeah so they basically
said well now we have to get all the
[ __ ] out of here and they have to tear
it down so sometimes the houses do have
to get torn down just because the people
didn't take care of them and they just
like got so moldy or you know falling
apart or rotten that they could when I
remember did he clean the whole house
out and then the the walls didn't meet
the floor anymore yeah that's right the
garbage and eating it eating the floor
yeah so you could see outside the house
the garbage was holding the damn wall
together pretty much yeah and they were
like and then the [ __ ] floors were
just [ __ ] yeah they're getting ready
because it was just filled with [ __ ]
cat [ __ ] and dead cats
remember that one yeah that [ __ ] I mean
that was more than one and they found
like dead animals yeah the [ __ ] woman
living in there was pissing on the floor
and [ __ ] [ __ ] it was and they just
said no the house has got to go they got
it cleaned out but then they came later
and they just [ __ ] tore it down the
whole house bulldozed it bulldozed it
[ __ ] just hauled it up I mean when
you have the hoarders that keep all
their garbage because some of them do
like it's not just people that it's like
oh we just buy [ __ ] and put it in the
pile of the house which is bad too but
some people um can't throw anything away
so their house is full of garbage yeah
um which means there's rats and roaches
and all kind of other stuff and it's
just the walls mold and the floor molds
and everything just starts falling apart
yeah you know it's pretty gross
block frog said my friend made me laugh
so hard once outside and later a cop
came and said the neighbors heard a
woman screaming later we were like dude
I think that was because of my laugh
yeah I wonder if that's what it was
that was like that's super funny
uh all right so where was I
um
uh
uh oh okay so they thought they heard a
woman screaming so this freaks them out
and they start running back toward the
house uh and then Mike at some point
gets his foot Tangled in a Vine or some
[ __ ] uh and I was like oh is this gonna
go like all evil dead this is we had
Amityville Horror now it's kind of coat
Evil Dead like the plants are coming to
get him
um so Matt like comes back to help him
and then the other kid comes back too
like the one that you know kind of
[ __ ] off like near the beginning
before they even heard the screaming he
comes back just so he can provide a jump
scare you know what I mean because like
while the kids are oh my God I gotta
help you rank oh my God legs oh it's you
you know what I mean so it was that kind
of things they did a jump scare right
there with that other that guy's like
what I didn't do anything all right so
once they're back at the house
Mike tells his mom what he heard in the
woods and she kind of gets bad at him
she's like well you know I you need to
stay out of the woods because it's too
dangerous she's like whatever it is
that's out there we don't want to know
which you know that's fair enough
so Clara says at this point
um she started to suspect that something
was wrong although they're still kind of
like trying to dismiss it
um because she said you know we had a
great life other than that so it was
easier to just be like oh maybe it's our
imagination or some [ __ ] like that
so one day uh Phil the dad is taking the
kids Tina and Mike into town and Clara
wants to stay home alone to kind of like
relax and read and you just will be
quiet for a couple of hours while
everyone else is gone
so she's laying on the couch with her
book and everything she's got all the
windows open because I guess the weather
is nice and then she said one of the I
don't know if she saw this or heard it
or what but the way that they showed it
on the reenactment was that one of the
open Windows like slammed shut like by
itself
and then she was kind of like what the
[ __ ] and like she got up to check and
then when she got up to check all the
windows were still open
so it's like I don't know if she
actually saw the thing close and then
when she got up it wasn't closed or if
she just heard it slammed clothes and
then got up you know what I mean it
looked like she looked at it
like closing and they showed it closing
but then I was like oh that's pretty
weird but she was like yeah when I went
and looked all of them were still open
so she's like I didn't really understand
what had happened so there was that
now a few nights after that Mike is
sleeping in his bed and then like some
stuff that's on the Shelf like above him
I don't know why you would put stuff
like on a shelf like right over your
head like this especially like heavy
[ __ ] but you know
um so stuff starts to kind of like slide
out and fall on him so it's like a chess
set in a box and it was like a check
like a box of checkers you know what I
mean so he looks up there and he sees
the [ __ ] like scooting like out like by
itself and he's weirded out because he's
like the games were underneath a pile of
magazines but the magazines didn't fall
so it's almost like like the boxes were
kind of like coming out from underneath
the pile of magazines so he's like what
the [ __ ] and like he calls his mom and
you know she was kind of freaked out too
she's like you know Mike is really
logical so he wouldn't have just like
made that up because he was saying to
her he's like look the [ __ ] like scooted
out from underneath the pile of magnet
and then the magazines just went like
that he's like that can't really happen
I don't know any law of physics that
would allow that
so um after that Claire is like she
started to think that whatever it was in
the woods that they had been hearing uh
was maybe coming in the house now so
yeah that is this is kind of like the
the last weak one you know
Tom Sykes said Tom did you make that
split piece if you had the Reagan vomit
no he hasn't made it yet we still got
the ham like but you know we had a ham
sandwiches early I'll tell you what I
did do we went down to the dam got some
more ice right there oh thanks went down
to the dollar store and Little Debbie
came out with a new dessert I said
oatmeal pies they're called
Snickerdoodle pies it's like two
Snickerdoodle snickerdoodle cookies
back to back with uh that marshmallow
cream filling out of the oatmeal pie and
I got them
they just they just they're new and they
it seemed like they had more cream
filling that was like poofier yeah Jenny
like them too yeah I liked him too if
you like snickerdoodle cookies man
they're real good and weirdly I don't
love the oatmeal pies because I don't
usually like that marshmallow cream but
for some reason it really works with the
Snickerdoodle and it's very cinnamony
which I like yeah you get two boxes of
them for five dollars two big old boxes
good old Dollar General yeah they got
all the little Debbies we still can't
buy them up though man they're gone they
get you know what else they had the
hostess and then they had Little Debbie
um
um Donuts you know they got the little
powdered Donuts a little chocolate
donuts too do you know yeah Little
Debbie make those I got some in the bag
or right around Halloween I got a bag of
pumpkin spice ones okay like little mini
Donuts they already mini Donuts yeah
they were they were powders but they had
like pumpkin spice in them they were
pretty good actually they were like
spice cake yeah the powdered Donuts are
so good when you microwave them just for
a few seconds man yeah
they come out of the deep far he's
getting like distracted by him that's
again yeah I was cheap Donuts yeah cheap
Dollar Store hey man you gotta like I
don't mind I'm I'm not a I'm not a
dessert snob yeah I'll eat pretty much
any dessert to be honest with you it's
all good
it's like some little bit of happiness
it's only costs a dollar then that's
even better
so uh so yeah so the the ship falls on
his head and he's like weirded out by it
so at this point Clara goes to a nearby
University to talk to a Catholic priest
about the problem because that's what
you do I guess you was raised Catholic
although she didn't say she was
particularly religious but you know she
thought well that's what you do so they
call the guy father Al I think his name
is alfonsius or something like that I
found it somewhere else but I don't
think they mentioned it on the show
so he's kind of seems like specifically
into paranormal stuff so he immediately
thinks like after she describes what's
going on that he might be that it might
be a poltergeist like you said
and he gives like a pretty accurate
description of what a poltergeist is
and Clara though she said well she was
kind of dubious about that because she's
like well she's like from what I knew of
poltergeist they didn't really seem to
have a mind behind them like I guess
like intention or something they do
though I know but I'm just saying that's
just in her perception so she's like so
she thought that whatever was Haunting
the house like seemed to have an
intelligence behind it or an intent
behind it and she was under the you know
under under the uh of the opinion that
Poltergeist didn't have that so she
wasn't really sure if that's what it was
but that's pretty much the first thing I
like yeah and like I said I'm not sure
exactly what the real guy said but I
like that this guy was just kind of like
oh yeah that sounds like a poltergeist
like he didn't do like oh it's a demon
or or anything like or have you guys
been playing with a Ouija board or
anything like that he immediately jumped
to Poltergeist which is probably if it
happened the way it happened he was an
educated priest yeah well like I said he
had seemed to yeah he seemed to like um
know a lot about like parapsychology
type thing or he seemed to be interested
in that kind of stuff
so he's like well tell you what um I'll
come out to the house and do a mass if
that will make you feel better and then
we'll see what we can see
so he comes out and does the thing
now Clara said you know I went to
Catholic school when I grew up and she's
like I was kind of under the mistaken
impression that you get you know from
the movies and everything you get the
priest to come out and he does the mass
and then everything's fixed like you
know Bob's your uncle it's like the end
of it so the whole family like
participates in the mass like expecting
that this is gonna fix it you know
um one night though while Phil is away
on business
Clara is asleep and then she's awakened
by something that sounds like I guess it
sounds like a girl like giggling or
laughing or making some kind of noise
like outside her room like in the
hallway
so she goes out and she sees she's like
walking down the stairs and she sees a
girl like walking along the hall now
first she thought it was her daughter
Tina
because she just kind of I guess Sarah
from the back but then like the girl
opened a door and went into a room which
I guess was Tina's room but then like
she runs down there and opens the door
to Tina's room and Tina is like sound
asleep in the bed and there's nobody
else in there they're wearing different
clothes too yeah and it was like
different clothes like you know what I
mean she said I guess it was kind of
dark but she said I thought it was Tina
at first but it wasn't you know what I
mean so I thought it was pretty weird
so in the morning uh Tina the daughter
she wakes up and you know says hi to her
little birdie like as soon as I saw that
little birdie in the cage I'm like oh
nothing bad's gonna have that birdie is
it nothing does and so I worried about
that too like when I saw the dog earlier
but nothing bad happens to the dog
either so I was just kind of like you
know just tell me so she's sitting in
front of the mirror
uh you know brushing her hair or
whatever and then she said she said that
she saw well I don't know if she saw
this she wasn't the real girl wasn't on
the show but she said there was like a
ghost of like a stringy-haired woman
like standing behind her like she sees
her in the mirror so she like starts
screaming bloody murder Clara comes
rushing in and uh her mom like she tells
her mom what she saw and then she
realized that the priest's mask didn't
do jack [ __ ]
um and she said that kind of surprised
her because like I said she'd always
been taught that that was what you did
and it was supposed to work like you
know it wasn't supposed to just keep
coming back
so Clara calls father Al tells him what
happened she's like I want my money back
I didn't pay for the [ __ ] but you know
what I mean
um and he says okay well this is clearly
beyond my pay grade so I'm gonna bring
in a paranormal expert out there like
ASAP
so
um that weekend though like Mike is out
with his friends Tina's sleeping in a
room Clara and Phil are watching TV
downstairs
and Phil hears something I don't I
couldn't tell what the sound was at
first but here's something that he turns
off the TV and then there's like a
breaking or kind of crashing sound from
outside so they go out with a flashlight
to check and see what the [ __ ] noise
was and while they're standing there
looking at the garbage cans all the
garbage cans gonna go like upended you
know what I mean so they assume it's
guess what raccoons
[Music]
yeah I haven't said that we were
watching the thing I was like where is
that raccoon because he even kind of
says it like that raccoons you know what
I mean he says it like that
so uh so they're kind of like looking
around the rest of the house just to
make sure that like nobody's breaking in
or anything so while they're looking in
one of the windows or passing one of the
windows from outside they see a girl in
the window like looking out at them so
at first like they think it's Tina so
they run back inside the house but then
they find Tina sitting in her room like
in front of her mirror they're calling
to her but she doesn't respond to them
like she just keeps staring at the
mirror and it's like super freaky and
her eyes are all black like they're not
all black like the pupils are black and
I guess I don't know what color her
normal eyes are but the actress's eyes
were blue so they kind of went all black
and it was like really freaky so she
kind of like comes to like a couple like
a second later and then she asked Clara
didn't she say something like um am I
going crazy or something like that yeah
um because she just like would like she
got possessed or some [ __ ]
so at this point Claire is like she was
starting to get really mad because the
thing is now like messing with her kids
so she's like I'm gonna kick this ghost
ass pretty much
so then they all hear something upstairs
like somebody walking around
so the phone rings Clara answers it and
it's Mike he's like hey can I stay over
with my friend Randy who that's whose
house he was at but Claire is like no
man like all kind of crazy paranormal
[ __ ] is going on so Mike's like okay
well I'm gonna come back so he comes
back home and brings Randy with him and
he pretty much tells Randy in the car in
the way he's like man all kind of like
weird [ __ ] is happening in my house
um and the grown-up Randy is also on the
show too like the real Randy he's also
on there too
because he saw some of the [ __ ] too
apparently
so they said the two of them Mike and
Randy they said when they got to the
house Phil the dad is running around
like a chicken with his head cut off
that's what they said so while they're
all in the front hallway kind of like
trying to figure out what to do because
all this weird paranormal [ __ ] that's
happening the lights they said the
lights all went off in the hall that
they were in even though the power was
still on and the rest of the house like
so it was just all the lights where they
were went out
so then they start hearing scratching
coming from the crawl space the thing
underneath the stairs common Poltergeist
sound effect yeah very scratchy scratch
that's what they do
um so they go to open it door sticks
again but they finally get it open and
this was pretty weird I think this was
like my best my favorite part so they
opened the crawl space door and they
find that all the bricks from the old
fireplace were now all stacked in the
middle of the floor typical Poltergeist
which is very weird to say the least and
like yeah Clara said it's like somebody
really like worked very hard
disassembling I mean I don't know what
it looked like in real life but on the
reenactment they said somebody had
disassembled this whole like facing of
the fireplace and there's just a pile of
bricks like in the middle of the floor
which would have taken some effort
I think a poltergeist ability can do it
quickly well yeah yeah I'm just saying
that
you can't be looking at it at the time
it's something something quantum
it's pretty uh yeah it's pretty weird
yeah pretty weird I guess objects aren't
are kind of massless when they're under
the influence of [ __ ] whatever
phenomenon is responsible for [ __ ]
Poltergeist it's some kind of quantum
physics yeah weird [ __ ] they could just
move [ __ ] around it just moves it and
switch it I've only caught a few things
actually moving and it's always out of
the corner of my eyes
and Jenny saw it but it's just it has
kind of a weird weightless movement to
it it's the sounds aren't right it's
just weird when you see it Tom's sake
said what state did this take place in
again it's uh New York it's Western New
York like um not too far from Buffalo
it's in a place called Hinsdale
uh murder Hornet asked if you got uh
your package yeah yeah
he got it
um okay
so yeah so Clara said that when they saw
that like the brick situation she said
that was when she realized uh this thing
is too strong for them to fight it
because it's like if it could do that
like immediately or whatever
um then yeah we're kind of hosed
so father Al comes back one night with a
psychic person named Alex Tannis yeah
who the guy they got playing this role
as a trip man
he's uh well he I mean you know he he's
committed to the role I like it I like
to see it he does everything very slow I
don't know if that's what the real guy
is like the real guy looks like he has
like a black Mustang he kind of looks
like Doug Henning if you guys remember
who that is like that magician from the
70s dude Scott
dude when he's doing the roll he's got
some serious gravitas
I'm not buying a word of what he's
saying though but no me neither yeah
but you know I like I said I appreciate
the actor that's in yeah yeah yeah
although I guess yeah like he went all
in which I respect that I respect that
uh the guy's last name if you want to
look at him up by the way because I was
thinking it was Tannis like Tannis root
like in Rosemary's Baby but it's not uh
it's
t-a-n-o-u-s which I never would have
guessed in a million years I would have
thought t-a-n-i-s but whatever uh so
apparently he did get studied by the
American study for psychical research
and I found out later that he had
actually written four or five books
um and was also the subject of a paper
in a in a journal called paranthropology
Journal of anthropological approaches to
the Paranormal
and uh this paper was called out of the
body and into the lab defining Dr Alice
tannis's abilities that was published in
2013.
so if you want to like look that up I
didn't like because like I said I don't
think I could read it because I think it
just had the um what do you call it you
it was like behind a paywall I never
heard of the guy
yeah I hadn't either but you know
uh I don't know I'll look more into him
later
so Alex goes into the crawl space so
whenever everybody says crawl space I
always think of like a literal crawl
space like you got to get down like a
crawl space this is like a closet it's
like a full you can walk into it it's
just like a closet it's a storage area
yeah underneath the damn closet yeah
it's like it's understood it's not a
crawl space yeah crawl space I I think
like you have to crawl into it yeah like
I would think that's why they call it
that hence the name
uh so he starts feeling some psychic
Vibes man
um and the family like starts to tell
him hey we got like some weird [ __ ] he's
like no don't tell me anything yeah and
then he does the thing like a lot of the
actors do like on the show when they're
having psychic Vibes they tilt their
head to the side and close their eyes
and yeah kind of squinch their face up
like oh yeah it is too painful the
Visions they are too painful yeah it was
just it was kind of like that yeah so
you just make a face like that so um so
they're like oh what are you seeing it
was like let's let's
people
over the years
some natural causes
some of them murders and they're going
whoa right that sounds like creepy but
we have to get down to the bottom of
this
see people love that [ __ ] it's like it's
like hearing a scary story around the
fire you know yeah like no like I said
nobody wants a psychic to come to your
house and be like yeah it's just nothing
but boring [ __ ] happened in your house
sorry yeah like everybody is like yeah
there was all kind of a serial killer
lived here this place was the place
where stagecoaches would stop the night
people were killing them and robbing
them of their money isn't that what he
said or something like that right yeah
that's what I was just getting to yeah
because he started he okay so he starts
having visions of bodies he has like a
little uh meeting with family in the
living room he's like I have a very
strong feeling that many people died in
this house some of natural causes yeah
some murdered yeah
he claims that the property used to be a
stagecoach stop
and he thinks that someone I'm presuming
somebody that lived in and or worked at
the house
um robbed and killed a bunch of
Travelers and stashed their bodies in
the crawl space until they could be
buried things like this did happen yeah
oh yeah I'm not saying that that's that
it's impossible like you know who was
that what was that [ __ ] uh show that
we did a long time ago about the family
yeah there's a family was doing it was
it anyway was it the bloody Benders yeah
and there was even other ones that were
selling their bodies as cadavers to
[ __ ] science if I remember correctly
too weren't they doing that in England
well yeah
um yeah no the doctors weren't asking
they weren't asking any questions well
Burke and hair did that yeah
well because after a while because you
know and I think we talked about this
when we talked about the Birkin hair
about broken hair was that for a while
uh you weren't really allowed
you know uh the cadavers that you cut up
like for medical research or you know
Anatomy classes or whatever they could
only be like criminals and [ __ ] like
that so they didn't have enough bodies
so there was like a pretty brisk Black
Market
in his body so people would like steal
bodies they wouldn't necessarily murder
people Burke and Herod did but
birkenhair started out just digging up
corpses like fresh ones and then they
were like you know it would go a lot
quicker if we just like [ __ ] cut out
the middle man and just killed the
people yeah and then we wouldn't have to
wait around for somebody to drop dead
you know what I mean
so yeah so that's what happens so Burke
and hair I think that's what actually
made the law change where it's like you
know there's a certain amount of bodies
that have to be like given to the thing
or whatever because before it they had
to be criminals because they thought it
was sacrilegious or something I guess
yeah like to cut bodies that went all
the way back to ancient Rome yeah
I don't think ancient Greece could do it
yeah a lot of countries did that Rome
actually banned at live animal
experimentation
because they had a guy who was cutting
pigs up alive and trying to figure out
how they worked [ __ ] man and yeah and
[ __ ] uh that's hard some Roman
Senators went to go see this you know
the guy had evidently made some really
great advances
and how the body works and Enrollment
Center saw then go no this is an affront
to the to the gods you know what I mean
in fact I mean it is you can't do this
and they [ __ ] banned they ban [ __ ]
live animal experimentation too that's
pretty [ __ ] up
well they wouldn't allow them [ __ ]
cutting cutting into [ __ ] cadavers
and [ __ ] that's what I mean it's like at
least at least it could go sideways
that's what I'm saying it's much better
to like let people cut up on cadavers
than [ __ ] live pigs for Christ's sake
yeah cadaver doesn't care they'd have
the [ __ ] pig tied up in a big thing
where it couldn't move and they'd go in
there and start you know do it operating
on it while it was alive and looking at
the heartbeat and then you know and all
that and see that's [ __ ] up yeah
vivisection yeah vivisection
but I can kind of understand it I do too
the best circumstances yeah yeah it's
still messed up there was a doctor doing
it
I wouldn't be making drawings and they
want to know what the heart actually did
you know [ __ ] um yeah I don't think a
whole lot of detail was left from but
that's just that's just all I remember
you're fascinated about the heart and
the lungs and all that
yeah that's up how did you know about
respiration yeah
they had to figure everything to figure
it all out yeah they didn't know [ __ ]
back then huh laughs
um but yeah so yeah it's not crazy to
think that because there was I mean
anytime you had uh like a hub of a place
like back in the old days where a lot of
people were stopping a lot of Travelers
were stopping then yeah you were gonna
get people that prayed on that situation
so it's not crazy to think that but I
don't think it happened in this
particular house you know what I mean so
their stash of the bodies in the crawl
space until they could be buried like I
said so he says that there are seven
spirits in the house
uh so Clara thinks wow like this dude's
legit you know what I mean like this is
the right guy to to have brought to the
house I guess
so after they leave Clara thinks that
just the psychic being there has like
calmed the place down because I guess
like The Haunting or whatever it was
like kind of chilled out for a little
while
Mike and Randy though
um probably wisely are kind of skeptical
of the psychic story so they decide
they're going to go into the woods one
night to see if they can find some kind
of proof that this did actually used to
be like a stage I don't know what they
were looking for exactly but you know
they were teenagers
so while they were out in the woods at
night though they see like the strange
lights like out in the trees in the
reenactment I guess it looked like a
bunch of orbs you know what I mean like
a bunch of little lights flying around
like that
so I don't know if that's exactly what
they saw but they did say it was kind of
weird uh Randy then said like he felt
like he couldn't breathe and he felt
like someone had him in a bear hug like
somebody was like just doing him like
that and he couldn't breathe like
squeezing him
so they ran back to the house and told
Clara mom
um they're like yeah we got to do
something about this [ __ ] because like
it's getting scary but Clara thinks it's
like well I don't think we should do
anything because it's dangerous and we
might get like [ __ ] over and at this
point while they're all like talking in
the front of the house like the doorknob
on the front door like starts turning
like ostensibly by itself you know like
the lock turns and everything so they're
just like Jesus Christ what's going on
so Clara is kind of like she's been
trying to hold it together this whole
time but she's kind of starting to lose
it a little bit because she's like look
we're gonna have to [ __ ] move because
like nothing we've done has like helped
and we can't really afford to move you
know it's kind of a situation where we
sunk all our money into this house and
[ __ ] like that like you do
and she was like also me and the kids
didn't really want to get beaten by
whatever this thing was anyway like I
didn't really they felt like they didn't
really just want to run away from it
now a few days after this a cop comes to
the door and tells Clara that Mike has
been in an accident now I'm assuming it
was a car accident he would I thought he
was only 14. that's what I said at the
beginning but then I think this maybe
happened over a longer time span because
when I read an article about it later
they said the family actually lived
there for four years
so I'm guessing that this happened and
they just like compressed it for the
show because you looked like the same
age because I'm like 14 year old kids
should not be driving but uh but yeah so
I'm assuming this happened like later on
when he was old enough to have a
driver's license
so Mike has a serious head injury and a
ruptured spleen so they actually had to
remove the spleen
so the state trooper said that when they
were pulling him out of the car like
after the accident Mike said that
someone else was in the car with him
but they couldn't find anybody else at
the scene and they're like it didn't
look like anybody else was in the car
did he have a head injury yeah yeah I
know what they're talking about I had
one of those too yeah no his memory was
[ __ ] up he probably thought he was
talking to somebody and everything
because his memories got all jumbled up
he's probably some of those memories
were like might have been from three or
four days before the accident
yeah because it's like your brain gets
all scrambled like in those kind of
situations and it kind of like messes I
woke up in the hospital there's somebody
last thing you remember and it says I
was talking to my friend Mike I was in
his I was talking to him in his living
room that bookcase fell on me the
bookcase yeah that's yeah that's why I
got hurt I thought the bookcase fell on
me what a weird thing to say because
that was my last memory so I thought a
bookcase to follow on me well wait did
you actually have a bookcase falling no
there was a bookcase behind me oh okay
that was the only thing that I that was
the last thing I remember so that was
what you thought was that thought
happened
no that was like four days ago
and I was like oh but then later the
memories came back the order started to
come you know what I mean I was like oh
yeah that's right yeah it didn't happen
then it's like because I can remember
the other day but it took weeks for me
to
re For The Memories always kind of start
falling back into place
that have actually got into a motorcycle
wreck I remember that happening kind of
right before it yeah but it's just
that's what happened to him
yeah probably there was nobody in a car
with him he just remembered another time
when he was driving with somebody that
was just one yeah I just think they they
kind of got um they mentioned it on the
show because I guess Clara
the mom like took him saying that as she
kind of like blamed whatever it was that
was Haunting the house for doing that to
her so like maybe it appeared in the car
and like made in wreck or something like
that I think that's kind of what they
were memories jumbled up that's probably
what I mean that's the that's the
Occam's razor explanation
so I get like Mike is in a coma for a
couple weeks I guess yeah uh but he
eventually wakes up and like I said
Clara started to believe that the entity
in the house had caused the accident
essentially I don't think she came right
out and said that but that was what the
implication was
so I guess uh Mike eventually recovered
and was fine because literally in the
next scene he's totally fine like he's
just standing there
and I was just like um okay so I guess
he's okay and spleenless
so then uh father Alan the psychic come
back to the house and they're gonna do
they're gonna one last attempt they're
gonna make to end this haunting God damn
it so they think they're maybe gonna try
and talk the ghost into leaving
voluntarily can you please leave Mr
ghost thank you so much
so the priest and the psychic go into
the house and start hearing creaking
like footsteps and then
Alex goes into Tina's room and does his
uh Vision thing again where he closes
his eyes and squinches his face up and
he said that he had a vision of a girl
that seemed like she was in pain like
lying in the bed then he hears like a
bunch of these creepy kind of ghostly
voices and senses a few other Spirits he
says that he saw like a boy who was 18
or 19 who came in the house I guess from
the reenactment that this was supposed
to be the kid with the gun in the woods
that the boys had seen earlier okay but
I was sitting there thinking because we
were watching it he's like I see a boy
it's 18 or 19 and he came in the house
and I was like what he came in the house
and like shot some [ __ ] like
what but then like he didn't he just
went off and talked about something else
so I'm like what he just came in the
house and nothing I guess I don't know
um he's like all because all he said
yeah there are others here and it's like
getting really cold in here and bloody
blah so then he says that he sees one
very particularly angry spirit in the
room this is the young woman who they're
you're led to believe is the same one
that Tina saw in the mirror earlier
so this ghost woman is apparently
telling him that she doesn't want to
leave the house and she said that she
used to lock herself in this room and
not come out and I guess she still
doesn't want to come out she doesn't
want the other energies the other goes
to leave either because I guess she
likes having them as roommate so
basically I mean Alex tells her to get
the [ __ ] out but she seems to like argue
with him that's like in the reenactment
they just kind of have her standing all
creepily like over by the window you
can't really see her face and he's just
sitting there no no you have to leave
you you know what I mean so I don't know
what you must leave which I don't know
you must leave this house
murder Hornet said go hop my neighbor
right it's like go out the window and
like go down the street and like haunt
the woods or some [ __ ]
um so he tells her to he's like let go
let go but I guess she's not having it
she's like nope stay in here so [ __ ] off
so at this point uh Alex and father Al
they're going to attempt to release they
call it releasing the negative energy in
the house they're doing a common
exorcism that's so common which is
apparently all he can do without getting
permission from the higher ups because
he's like to do the big whiz bang like
exorcism you need to like you need
special permission please you can't just
go around doing exorcism's willy-nilly
who knows what might happen yeah you
might not abuse it
too much
bothering God too much oh here's this
[ __ ] yeah oh you doing this [ __ ]
yeah so they do the exorcism uh thank
you very much Senor sticks is this
another Amityville thing or Poltergeist
it was very Amityville yeah at least not
the first at least at first it seemed
like
um so yeah so they do the exorcism and
they do kind of like your standard thing
where they're all standing around in a
circle and like they do the flashy
lights and you know there's all kind of
creaky noises and everything and Clara
says it's like man looks like when it
was done she's like wow that was like
powerful like the ghosts have to leave
now like that was so awesome
um I'm gonna have to say too that the
actor that was playing Alex Tannis I
love loved his facial expressions during
the exorcism like he looked like he was
just taking an apocalyptic [ __ ] like the
whole time like just the way that he was
like scrunching his face up it was like
just making me laugh
um so
she says after they did the exorcism she
says that the place felt the word she
used was Blissful like after the extras
like it felt like they did when they
first moved it
so apparently though
uh it stayed like that for several
months but then uh The Haunting returned
later on in the year so the family
actually ended up having to move out and
they couldn't find a buyer for the house
and ended up having to declare
bankruptcy so this did not have a happy
ending
um Clara actually said too that the
whole ordeal really kind of like
diminished her faith in anything really
she said I was kind of got to the point
where I don't think formal religions
she's like I don't think that any one of
them have the one answer like maybe they
all have little pieces of the answer but
none of them have the entire one
um and she's like very few of them admit
that this kind of thing happens
so the the actual episode ends on this
kind of like slow Zoom like into the
house with the sound of flies or I guess
it's bees because it was bees at the
beginning but which is again like very
Amityville Horror
so when I looked this house up
oh
I need to take a drink I'm like not
getting able to I'm not being able to
like drink my drink because I'm like
talking too much yeah
so um when I looked up this house
apparently this house is pretty well
known in paranormal circles
uh as I mentioned it actually turns up
on TripAdvisor you can I guess the guy
that owns it now like will give tours
and like let paranormal groups in there
to like investigate and a lot of them
have
um so since that is the case I don't
feel bad saying what the address is the
address is actually 3830 McMahon Road
that's
mtna h-o-n in Hinsdale New York
now according that I did find some [ __ ]
about this house like on another site
so that was kind of like
um trying to clear up some
misconceptions I guess
so uh and like I said the woman Clara
she actually wrote a book about it as
well
so the family lived there for four years
and they had a bunch of weird
apparitions of multiple people they said
they all saw a movement of objects
unexplainable since they didn't really
get into that in the show
uh unexplained sounds yeah
so uh when the family asked the guy to
do the blessing now what this particular
site said is like on the show they said
that he did a common exorcism they said
in real life they didn't he just did a
house blessing so I don't know what it's
not a huge difference but whatever
um actually the family when the [ __ ] hit
the fan like when the Paranormal [ __ ]
was getting really bad they actually had
an article about them published in a
local paper and then everyone started
making fun of them
so you know what I mean yeah uh so Alex
Tannis did come there like uh and he did
claim that there were seven he actually
said there were seven murders in the
house
I think on the show they said yeah he
said there were some murders in the
house but he said there were seven
ghosts in the house but he specifically
said there were seven murders now are
they claiming this phenomenon is still
going on I don't know actually
um I think that from what I saw like I
looked on TripAdvisor and there was like
a couple it looked like a couple of
paranormal groups had been there like
recently like in the past few years yeah
and some of them had like set up their
stayed overnight or something like that
and they're like yeah we didn't really
have anything happen or we had like a
couple like you know like [ __ ]
things it's Poltergeist kind of thing
you know what I mean it's Poltergeist it
was the people in there not not the
house that's all I'm saying yeah
um so yeah so like I said even though on
the show they said it was an exorcism it
wasn't it was a blessing like I said
well they might be calling it a blessing
a very common form of exorcism yeah the
words that they they play word games you
know and I guess even though they didn't
mention this on the show I guess one
very common misconception about the
house in paranormal circles is uh that
it was built on guess what in Indian
burial ground yeah
um but uh that is not the case
uh now the [ __ ] that Alex Tana said
about oh this used to be an in or a
stagecoach stop where people got
murdered uh there is no evidence that
anyone can find that it was ever used as
a stagecoach in now uh one of the there
there were kind of like stories that the
road that there was a road that went
past the house like that stage coaches
went by on so it's entirely possible
that people could have stopped there
like in a stagecoach and stuff but it
wasn't an in or anything like that now
there is another legend about this house
which they didn't mention on the show
um but that there's a tree called The
Hanging Tree which is near the house and
that it was used for hanging people uh
most famously a pregnant woman uh named
Elizabeth that's the story uh but again
there's no evidence that that's true
either there's also another Legend
likely they didn't execute women that
were pregnant no because I was killing
two people they'd let her give birth and
then they'd [ __ ] connect and then they'd
execute her hey let's let's wait until
she pops and then yeah
um also there's another legend that
there was a boy that was killed in a
buzz saw accident on the property
now there was a boy that was killed in a
buzz saw accident matter of fact but he
actually wasn't killed on that property
he was killed like somewhere else you
know what I mean so I think people are
like conflating two things
so I also found an article from 2017. oh
by the way uh Clara Miller Clara Miller
Dandy she's like the mom that was on
here her name's Clara Miller now she
wrote a book about this house and it was
called Echoes of a haunting I don't know
how available it is but she wrote it so
there you go
um so I found a an article from 2017
that was about this as well and it just
kind of went a little bit into I guess
there's a guy at least as of 2017 the
guy that owns it now is named Dan clice
I guess is how you pronounce his last
name and like I said he lets people
um he's actually the co-founder of the
greater West New York Paranormal Society
so I guess he bought the house
specifically because of its reputation
and he lets paranormal group stay there
evidently and like he runs tours and
[ __ ] like that and people apparently
still have things happen there like one
of the things that was in this article
was this kid uh was in the house and
like sat on the bed and said that he saw
an angry Indian looking at him I guess
that's because of the of the legend
about it Indian burial brand and all
that stuff but like I said it's not it's
not Andy Berry
um but yeah so you know and there's
still the whole thing too the legend
about it was a couple of Brothers who
lived there and raided stage coaches and
blah blah but I don't know if that's
true or not like they don't they don't
find anything what you're seeing here is
that
there's a good chance that a Poltergeist
episode happened in this house
the people who actually were the focuses
of it left but this the legend lived on
though [ __ ] the market want to turn
it into a damn haunting
and then of course what are they going
to do murders Indian burial grounds yeah
pissed off Indians all your standard
troops that's right
that's what so they're just they're
making this [ __ ] Hollywood as [ __ ] okay
and then they try to sell tickets to it
the phenomena is probably not going on
anymore probably long gone it was those
kids
it was rspk
most likely if if anything was happening
there that's that's far more likely
uh than
haunted houses
well the good news is if you actually
want to see if there's still anything
going on in the house
uh there is actually a Hinsdale house
that's what it's called live stream
and uh it's going on all the time like
they just live stream the inside of the
house it's on Facebook live on the page
of the Hinsdale house restoration
project and I looked at it today and
it's still going on yeah I mean it's
boring as [ __ ] because you're just like
looking at a room but you know if you're
into that kind of stuff maybe something
exciting definitely sure haunted houses
exist in the way in reality is in the
same way that they exist in
folklore in these reports I haven't seen
it I've been in bad houses
um
give you bad feelings but I never saw
anything move in them couldn't prove it
you know just feelings
and how do you prove feelings
you know feeling feelings yeah nothing
hard to prove
well yeah because they're subjective
yeah consistently people would go in
there and go and be afraid in there you
know like someone's watching them but
like I said nothing ever moved
so so that's the thing yeah you can't
really can't really prove anything right
because no yeah that's everyone's like
subjective yeah did somebody send us a
Super Chat yeah I got that a while back
okay yeah
but uh yeah that's the end of my notes
so like I said if you want to go to the
Hinsdale house restoration project
Facebook page you can watch a live
stream of the inside of the house look
at Jenna Jenny's [ __ ] show in
cleavage today been a long time Jenny
you keeping those you copy kept those
[ __ ] leashed and holstered you've now
unholstered your femininity coming at
them both barrels
okay it's [ __ ] fantastic
I missed what are you talking about you
see them all the time
that's right
thank you again Senora six yeah so Tom
and Jenny Ghost Hunter show now on
sci-fi yeah man [ __ ] the thing is is
that I'd love to have a ghost on a show
problems wouldn't make any money because
I don't think anybody's watching cable
anymore
well you could do one on a streaming
service but see the thing is that yeah
you would have to come up with like a
good angle because they're so [ __ ]
many there's our normal shows you really
have to have a unique angle and I don't
know if I could think of one my angle
would be this
I know that shit's real I've seen this
kind of [ __ ]
but I also call [ __ ] on most of it
um I there are real cases that inspire a
lot of fakes and then there are a lot of
people who bring a lot of baggage to the
table if something does go down they're
projecting into it seeing what they want
to see to
to
um you know back up some kind of [ __ ]
belief system when I saw Poltergeist I
thought it was a ghost because that my
belief system could could get behind
that it took a long time weeks for me to
go now this isn't really a ghost this is
a different phenomenon you know it was a
ghost alike that it was an artificial
ghost
it was [ __ ] rspk
thing though I feel like
I think the problem with that like I
would watch a show like that but I feel
like most people that watch Ghost Hunter
type shows they don't want like a
skeptical they just want to watch
something that's like creepy yeah and so
they can like imagine it's like ooh you
know look at that orb or like ooh look
at this you know I don't know but I feel
like that's kind of like because
whenever they would do a show that had a
more skeptical angle to it like it
seemed like it never did all that well I
don't think people want to be like think
about
that it's not real
paranormal phenomena is rare and
intermittent and you can't
depend on it it happens when you least
expect it and most of it isn't ghost
it's [ __ ] like you have a dream and a
dream comes true you have a feeling so
you act on that feeling and it saves
your life uh you you have a premonition
that something might bad it might it
might happen might be bad so you said
I'm going home
I had that happen bad [ __ ] started
happening to us on the way to the club
got to the club and said Jenny I'm
getting out of here there's something
not right we left and then that Pulse
Nightclub shooting happened up the road
remember Pulse Nightclub shooting what
are they doing there shout out to gay
bar that was like a mile up the road
from there and I just had and we were
out there we were out that night and I
just had a I said Jenny something's not
right man it feels bad here this is I
feel a lot of Anger from these people
Jenny's probably like oh you're you're
full of [ __ ] so I'm getting I don't want
to be here left and then we went back in
that pulse night well I was like I was
mad because we'd driven all the way down
there but I'm used to like fun because
Norm you wouldn't you don't normally do
that yeah so yeah and so my instincts
are true
um but see I don't think that that's
Supernatural I think some people might
say that it's supernatural but I think
that people are a lot more I never said
Supernatural yeah it's paranormal no I'm
saying yeah I didn't say you did I'm
just saying that like some people do
like they would say that as oh I'm
psychic or something like that but I
don't think it's that weird I think most
people have that
um ability it's just that you don't
usually listen to it without listening
to it it's an animal Instinct as part of
it it's what Obi-Wan says is just let go
of your [ __ ] your waking conscious
self and just [ __ ] let your feelings
take over you know just kind of feel
your way you see it in your mind that's
just it's like that it's you're not
it's not rational it's irrational but
it's not insane it's listening to
ancient instincts is what it's like well
because I think a lot of stuff like
you're picking up on a lot of
environmental clues that you're not
consciously aware of I think is what it
is self-conscious minds are really good
yeah analog [ __ ] super computer it's
a quantum computer and I believe a lot
of it is happening outside your skull
and it's it's it's interconnected with a
Quantum Universe [ __ ] vague
information where there's like a [ __ ]
internet out there that you have kind of
access to kind of like kind of like how
a radio has access to the radio spectrum
yeah it's something like that
that's how animals know to do certain
things at certain times and which
direction to fly for the winter you know
it's like that it's that kind of thing
you know yeah they're not they're not
worried about [ __ ] like we're working
yeah yeah they're just doing what they
feel she's right you know and it and
it's they feel right it feels right to
them for a [ __ ] reason you know but
they're not analyzing it they're not
thinking about it I wonder why Pookie
feels that it's right that she wants to
go in the closet all the time because
she wants to tear up [ __ ] shoes
[Laughter]
has all kinds of weird feelings like
biting Daddy
play biting daddy she loves to bite and
to wrestle she doesn't bite hard she
just wants to play yeah I've never had
her bite hard she knows she knows not to
she knows she's just playing it's just
playing you know wrestling and biting
and [ __ ] running and coming back and
falling on her back okay we can't talk
about the cats
hey I was I was done with my dad so it's
okay okay
you shut this [ __ ] down are you really
what you what are you gonna make did you
tell me and I forgot well I'm not even
drunk I've only like this is uh this is
strawberry moonshine by the way you
notice that it tastes better once it
Waters down a bit well yeah because I
mean it's kind of strong yeah
um you know
the uh I don't know
I got a bunch of ham I want some ham and
eggs
yeah that sounds good sounds good yeah
fried eggs and ham sounds good if I have
enough eggs we'll see Tom Sykes said
it's a dark place cats like Dark Places
yeah she likes tearing up shoes I think
that's the main thing that's all it is
she knows she likes she's like she knows
she's in the class she's like oh I can
totally like claw those shoes yeah she
cuts the clawed and doing all this on
shoes and sharpen her in her closet it's
kind of like she's drooling it's like a
it's like a sexual thing or something
okay get ready all right so thank you
everybody for dropping by this evening
talking about hauntings and [ __ ] like
that so tomorrow we'll be back for
another movie review and we're going to
be doing night of the Comet because
that's what everybody voted for well
that's what the people on patreon voted
for so that's what we're gonna do and
like I said I feel like a lot of people
have recommended that and like I feel
bad because I'm like yeah we'll get
around to it yeah we'll get in so we
haven't got around to it but we're gonna
get around to it we'll watch it tonight
and we'll talk about it tomorrow so
thank you everybody for super chats
thanks for dropping by and we'll see you
guys again doing a movie review tomorrow
good night
[Music]
thank you